other celebrity related news but quite a  generous event here taking place one of  las vegas top chefs joining the effort  to help ukrainian refugees that is jose  andres he's stepping up again a few  hours ago his world central kitchen  non-profit arrived at the polish border  there you see him there andres has  several high-end restaurants on the las  vegas strip of course and whenever  there's a big disaster going on whenever  there's a crisis around the world cherry  you can depend on jose to show up there  with his team of staff and folks  volunteering and feeding the people that  need help right now he's quite a  remarkable man he never holds back it's  pretty amazing he always shows up to  help